tras confirmarse el triunfo de joe biden
en la elección presidencial de eeuu
algunos analistas mexicanos consideran
que podría venirse al inicio una
relación complicada dada la visita que
hizo lópez obrador
el presidente mexicano a donald trump en
plena campaña electoral que fue
interpretada por algunas voces como un
apoyo a la candidatura del republicano
sin embargo el representante del partido
demócrata en méxico richard weber ha
descartado una actitud de revanchismo de
parte de bailén pues dice viene con el
ánimo de construir en ese sentido un
bloque de una decena de gobernadores de
oposición agrupados en la alianza
federalista ha felicitado a bailén ya su
vicepresidenta kamala harris y han
expresado su interés de que esto sea el
inicio de una nueva relación basada en
el respeto sobre todo hacia nuestros
paisanos esto luego del trato que dio la
administración de trump pero también la
política de deportaciones masivas de
barack obama donde yo va a tener a
vicepresidente otro tema sin duda
importante en la relación bilateral será
el de la seguridad y la cooperación en
este
el presidente lópez obrador dijo que
cuando se resolviera la elección se
vería lo de la captura del general
salvador cienfuegos que fuera secretario
de la defensa con un operativo secreto
de la dea